happy sabbath again and welcome to
question and answer with elder randy
skeet on the word inspired i'm your host
denise mccurchin and i'm joined by
special guests elder randy skeet sister
alana kwashi sister joanna smith and
sister shirelle pierre and today we will
be discussing the resurrection and
answering questions like what is the
resurrection what is its purpose
what will be the body of the righteous
when they are resurrected do we have
hope after death
stay tuned as we seek to answer these
questions by god's grace and be generous
with the word like share and subscribe
and we pray that you are blessed as we
seek to ascertain this fundamental
belief of the bible
let us pray
dear heavenly father we thank you for
this opportunity to learn of you we ask
that you forgive us of our sins and we
welcome your presence in our midst
please direct the proceedings of this
program and we ask the lord that you
would receive the honor the glory and
the praise in jesus name we pray amen
all right so we are moving right along
today
we are joined by international speaker
elder randy skeet he is a husband and a
humble man of god
he's a graduate of oakwood university
and also of the seventh-day adventist
theological seminary at andrews
university where he studied for the
ministry as he would say
i ask that you pray that god will put
his words in his mouth
let's listen be reverent and think as he
speaks please welcome elder randy skeet
thank you very much dr denisha it's
always my pleasure to join you
in these programs which i value very
highly i think
they serve a very very significant role
and so i am delighted to be here
and i pray that the spirit of god will
direct my remark so that those who
listen will be blessed [clears throat]
by the truth it is the truth alone that
makes a person free according to john 8
32 and in verse 36 it is christ that
makes you free so at the highest level
truth is christ and so my intention is
to deliver thus saith the lord and hope
that someone listening will be blessed
particularly if there's someone
listening who's not a seventh adventist
i am very glad that you're with us and
may the lord enlighten your mind to a
degree that brings you closer and closer
to him and may god bless all those
associated with this program i'm ready
to answer the questions as the spirit
directs amen thank you for that prelude
elder skeet
the first question
you know we we like to put them together
it has two parts the first part is what
is the resurrection and the second part
is what is its purpose all right i need
to pray i didn't do that father in
heaven as i respond to questions from
your people give me wisdom
it is promised in james chapter one
verse five if any of you lack wisdom let
him ask of god i ask you now not for my
sake but for the sake of those whom you
love who are listening that your name
may be glorified in the truth and their
lives blessed in jesus name i pray amen
the resurrection is that glorious event
where the dead shall return
from the grave
uh two kinds will return the just and
the unjust for two different reasons the
just to live with christ forever the
unjust to see why they are lost why they
will be punished and then to receive the
due punishment and so we have the
resurrection mentioned in daniel chapter
12 verse 2 and many of them that sleep
in the dust of the earth shall awake
some to everlasting life some to share
an everlasting damnation we have
resurrection mentioned in john 5 28
marvel not at this that the hour is
coming in the which all that in the
grier shall hear his voice and shall
come forth they that have done good
under the resurrection of life they have
done evil under the resurrection of
damnation this is christ we have it in
first
thessalonians 4 16 for the lord himself
shall descend from heaven with a shout
with the voice of the archangel are with
the trump of god and the dead in christ
shall rise first of course first
corinthians 15 is fully dedicated to the
concept of the resurrection and so it is
a fundamental uh teaching of the bible
because without the resurrection there
is no gospel because the purpose of the
gospel is to restore things as they were
before adam's sin
there was no death before adam saying
there must be a resurrection so that
those who have given their lives to
christ can enjoy that endless life with
him john 3 16 says for god so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son
that whosoever believeth in him should
not perish but have everlasting life in
order to have that everlasting life
people must be ransomed from the grave
through the blood of christ and so the
resurrection is the coming up out of the
grave two kinds of people the first in
the first resurrection to live with
christ the second to receive the
punishment
and uh so that's the resurrection and
when it will happen
thank you so much elders [clears throat]
and you know this is so key that you
mentioned how interconnected the
resurrection is with the hope of the
christian because our foundation is
built on the fact that jesus lives
if jesus did not resurrect then our
preaching is in vain [clears throat] our
faith is in vain we have no hope but
thank god for the hope and the power of
the resurrection that we have in jesus
there's a reason why christ had there
must be a resurrection yes
god promised abraham for instance in
genesis chapter 13
verse 14 the bible says and god said
unto abram after that lot was separated
from him lifted now then eyes and looked
from the place with our northward and
southward and eastward and westward for
all the land which thou seest to thee
will i give it and to thy seed forever
that's what he promised him in verse 17
he tells abraham arise walk through the
land to the length of it and the breath
of it for i will give it unto thee and
it is repeated in chapter 15 it's
repeated in 17 god would give abraham
the land and his seed but hebrews 11 13
tells us these all died in faith
not having received the promises but
having seen them afar off and were
persuaded of them and embrace them so
abraham isaac and jacob the three
great patriarchs with whom god is
closely associated because he's god of
abraham isaac and jacob they did not
receive the land literally in their
lives they died as strangers in the land
where they lived
god must come back to fulfill his
promise to abraham also when god told
abraham lifted now then eyes and look
from the place with our northward and
southward and eastward and westward that
was a reference to the entire world
it was the time when lot had chosen the
fertile plains around sodor and left the
rough area in the hills for abraham god
rejoined abraham the day will come when
you will receive the entire world and
paul makes this absolutely clear in
romans 4 13 where he said and the
promise that he should be the heir of
the world was not to abraham through the
law but by the righteousness of faith
and so when god promised abraham the
land he promised him the whole world
there were two levels of fulfillment the
israelites did come in and possess the
land but on a wider scale it will be
given to the meat who shall inherit the
earth and those are the ones who have
given their lives to christ and so god
must come back
to keep his promise to abraham because
the bible says in titus chapter 1 verse
2 god cannot lie and in numbers 23 19 he
does not lie he must come back he must
resurrect abraham and his seed and his
seed refers to anyone who's accepted
christ
he must come back resurrect them and
finally keep his word fully there must
be a resurrection
amen amen thank you for that addendum
elder skeet
so we have covered what the resurrection
is its purpose and you have already
stated that there will be two general
resurrections the resurrection of the
just and of
[clears throat] when they take place the
resurrection of the just at the coming
of jesus christ and the resurrection of
the unjust after the millennium that's
right
are there exceptions to this in other
words have resurrections already taken
place in the bible
yes they have
uh lazarus was resurrected but he died
again you see
uh the widow of nay in luke 7 her son
was resurrected from the dead but of
course he died again
uh elijah is a widow's son elijah is
someone said paul raised someone uh
uticus peter raised someone but they all
died again the resurrection we're
talking to is the resurrection from
which there will never be any return to
the graves this is a resurrection to
enjoy eternal life without interruption
life with christ so yes they have been
resurrections before but they are not
the resurrection spoken out in uh john
14 1-3 let not your heart be troubled
even god believe also in me i go to
prepare a place for you if i go i will
come again
this i will come again is that general
resurrection
where the the just shall receive the
reward and a thousand years later the
wicked shall be raised to receive theirs
which is total punishment
now there was also a resurrection in
matthew 27 from verse 50. this is a
special resurrection let me pray again
before i continue lord continue to
instruct me as i speak in jesus name i
pray amen matthew 27 50 jesus when he
had cried again with a loud voice
yielded of the ghost and behold the veil
of the temple was rent entwined from the
top to the bottom and the whole earth
did quake and the rocks rang and the
graves were opened and many bodies of
saints that slept awoke or rose and came
out of the graves after his resurrection
and went into the holy city unappeared
to many matthew 27 50-53 there was a
special resurrection when jesus rose and
those people when he went back up to
heaven uh
40 days later he uh he took them with
him that's why we read in ephesians
chapter four
first aid wherefore he saith
when he ascended upon high he led
captivity captive they were captive to
the graves he released them and he took
them with him now they also represent
what the bible calls the first fruits
in first corinthians 15 reading from
verse 19 the bible said if in this life
only we have hope in christ we are of
all men most miserable verse 20 but now
is christ risen from the dead and has
become the first fruits of them that
slept but along with christ are those
who came up with him all together they
represent the first fruits now the first
fruit was one of the seven annual feasts
and i hope i'm not saying too much but
the first fruit was one of the seven
annual feasts the jews the israelites
were required to to keep
they're in order of their occurrence one
the pastor and all seven are found in
leviticus chapter 23 first one passover
second one feast of 11 bread third one
feast of first fruits the fourth feast
of wheat which in the new testament is
called pentecost the fifth one the feast
of trumpets the sixth day of atonement
and adventists know very well about the
day of atonement and the last one was
the feast of tabernacles celebrating
finally our entrance into god's kingdom
now if we look at cease number one and
two leviticus 23 reading from verse five
the bible said in the 14th day of the
first month at even
is the the passover
the lord's passover verse 6 and on the
16th day of the same month is the feast
on the 15th day of the same month is the
feast of unleavened bread unto the lord
seven days you must eat eleven bread in
the first day is unholy convocation he
shall do no survival but you shall often
offering me by far unto the lord seven
days in the seventh day is unholy
convocation you shall do no survivor
therein now if we look carefully at
verse five and verse six
in verse five we have the fourteenth day
in verse 6 we have the 15th day which
means we have two days
look at verse 5 of leviticus 23
in the 14th day of the first month at
even
is the lord's passover that's day one
now we know the pastor represents the
sacrifice of christ
because in first corinthians chapter
five verse seven the bible says the last
part of that verse for even christ our
passover is sacrificed for us calvary is
the passover fulfilled and so the
passover which began the same night they
left egypt commemorates the departure
from egypt and represents the
deliverance from the land of sin the
passover represents the death the
sacrifice of christ it occurred on the
14th day of the fif of the first month
now the very next day was the first day
of the feast of 11 bread which ran for
seven days but the first day of those
seven were treated like a sabbath he
shall do no survival therein the bible
says in a verse seven of uh six on seven
of leviticus 23
christ died on a friday which actually
was a fulfillment of
leviticus 23 the very next day was the
sabbath a literal sabbath you see now in
this in the in the feast time
the ceremonial sabbath could fall any
day of the week but when christ died the
next day was the literal sabbath that's
why it was called a high sabbath because
it was both the
creation sabbath and the ceremonial
sabbath was called the high sabbath then
the very next day is when the first
fruits were ways before the lord
that first fruit represents the harvest
that was to come
which god would accept now it was
brought to the priest and the priest
would accept it for the people jesus
went up with those who brought from the
grave to present himself and them to god
that god might accept them as a way of
saying i will also accept the larger
harvest to come and so the resurrection
of christ on the third day is typified
in the feast of passover not passover
but unless and bread which began the
very next day after passover which was
the sabbath the seventh day of that
celebration was also sabbath and that's
a lot i'm trying to tell you at the
moment but that's where the resurrection
of christ is symbolized because paul
says in first corinthians 15 3 and 4
for i have delivered unto you first of
all that which i also received how that
christ dies our sins according to the
scripture and that he was buried and
that he rose again the third day
according to the scripture well where
does the scripture say he would rise the
third day you put in one and one
together you get two you realize in the
ceremony of the first fruit we have the
rising of christ
on the third day the same way the first
fruits were waved on the third day in
the old testament and so christ was the
firstfruit those who came up with him in
matthew 27 50 to 53 they were part of
that first fruit and jesus took them to
heaven with him a long response i hope
someone got something out of that
amen that was very rich elder skeet and
you made that connection
so clear in fact brother waldron is here
saying oh yes that special resurrection
is quite intriguing and oh yes that
sabbath was a high saddle
and uh a brown is asking us to repeat
the bible text that was quoted i believe
that was leviticus 23.
three start reading from verse five
there you go so leviticus 23 from verse
5. and you know i really like how you
how you made it clear how the
resurrection was spoken of and even
preached in the old testament because as
[clears throat] i was preparing for this
q a i opened up my concordance to look
for the word resurrection right and i
found that the the word resurrection
itself is not stated in the old
testament right
it's only stated verbatim in the
new testament but we know that it still
was preached and we see it in sanctuary
services and many other uh
characters in the bible like job
and even the book of daniel but i think
the word faith is only found but twice
in the old testament so it's very
interesting the word faith and the just
shall live by faith is almost never
found in the hotel i think once or twice
that's it
it does not mean it doesn't exist you
just have to study and you'll find it
right there in your face it's right
there
amen amen sister cassandra james is
saying what day was the ceremonial
sabbath held
the ceremonial sabbath was held on the
15th day of the first month
look at verse
15 of leviticus 23
and on the 15th day of the same month is
the feast of 11 bread unto the lord
seven days you must eat 11 bread in the
first day which is the first of the
seven
you shall have in holy convocation you
shall do no service therein but he shall
offer an offering made by fire to the
lord seven days in the seventh day is
unholy convocation he shall do no
survival so the seven days of unleavened
bread celebration began the day after
passover and that first day which was
the 15th was considered a sabbath and
the seventh was also considered a
sabbath
amen and a brown the text in first
corinthians obscured i believe it was
first corinthians chapter 15 from verse
one youth started first fifteen three
and four three and four the dead
according to the scriptures
so the scriptures in the old testament
must talk about the resurrection of
christ without using the word
resurrection
you see paul had no new testament
so he got it from the old
understand clearly the new testament
preachers
their bible was the old testament so all
that they thought was based on the old
testament by the way churches today who
say we are new testament churches they
don't know what they're saying the new
testament church was founded on the old
testament
but that's a different story okay
no but that absolutely [clears throat]
true search he is
all the preaching of christ was based on
the old testament because he had nothing
else
there you go
thank you elder skeet well i'm going to
turn it over to sister alana kwashi to
ask
the next three questions
thank you
for you're welcome
good afternoon everyone and happy
sabbats everyone and elder skeet that's
my sister
so the first question that i have is
what will be the state of our bodies
after
resurrection so it's three questions but
i'm going to ask you one by one so okay
our body the state of our bodies
the resurrection now if you go to luke
chapter 24 from verse 36
the disciples are in the upper room they
are scared to death they're expecting to
be done to them what was done to christ
he had told them he would rise mark 8 30
chap mark 9 mark 10 he told him he would
rise they didn't believe it now while
they're in the room the bible says and
as they thus speak that's luke 24 36
jesus himself stood in the midst of them
and saith unto them peace be unto you
but they were terrified and affrighted
and supposed that they had seen a spirit
now keep this word in mind they suppose
they had seen a spirit or a ghost he
said to them why are you troubled and
why do thoughts arise in your heart
behold my hands and my feet that it is i
myself handle me and see for the spirit
hath not flesh and bones as ye see me
have christ is saying i am not a spirit
now this is the risen christ i have
flesh i have bones
and when he is when he had thus spoken
he showed unto them his hands and his
feet and while they yet believe not for
joy and wonder he said of them have ye
hear any meat and they give unto him a
piece of a broad fishing of a honeycomb
verse 43 and he took it and he eat
before them before the means in the
present now christ is saying i have
hands i have feet i have bones i have
flesh and i eat i am not a spirit in
other words he came from the grave
physical keep this in mind now let's go
to philippians chapter three let's read
verses 20 and 21 of philippians 3 i'll
pray again father continue to tell me
what to tell your people in jesus name i
pray amen philippians 3 verse 24 our
conversation is in heaven the greek word
conversation means citizenship and by
the way that's literal if you are a true
child of god your citizenship is first
in heaven not in sweden or jamaica the
united states is in heaven now for our
citizenship is in heaven from whence
also we look for the lord this house of
the savior the lord jesus who shall
change our vile bodies that it might be
fashioned according to his glorious body
what does that tell us the body with
which christ came from the grave is the
body you and i will have
when we come from the grave and jesus
makes it clear in matthew in luke 24
36-43
he is physical he said i have flesh i
have bones i eat food a spirit does not
do that and so the answer to the
question is our bodies will be physical
flesh and bones we will eat that's why
we have the tree of life with 12 man in
frost a ghost does not eat
we will have a body like christ
glorified no longer subjected to illness
or whatever else or losing your hair
whatever else will have a perfect body
and that's the one christ had that's
what we'll have next question thank you
so the next question is what does
malachi 4 verse 2 mean about us growing
up as
cows of the stall so malachi 4 verse 2
says
but unto you that fear my name shall be
righteousness arise with healing in his
wings and
forth and grow up as cows of the stall
all right
a simple
when christ when we die let's say i'm
about six feet tall when i rise
i'll be six feet tall
but originally according to ella white
adam was about twice the height of men
living today so something has to change
when the son of righteousness arises
with healing these rings even in the new
world things will change in us we will
grow back to the original a statue we
had if you read revelation 22 verses 1
and 2 and he showed me a pure river of
water of life clear as crystal
proceeding out of the throne of god and
of the lamb in the midst of the street
of it on either side of the river was
there the tree of life
of the street was there a tree of life
which bear 12 man of fruit and yielded
the fruit every month and the leaves of
the tree were for the healing of the
nation changing will take place over
time as we live in this perfect world we
don't die six feet and rise 15 feet we
come up and physical changes take place
what changes immediately in the grave is
we're no longer able to die
but our stature will change you know
whatever else needs to come to the
original perfection that will happen
over time and so he shall go forth and
grow as calves of the soul so that is
what is meant by that
the literal growing up because in the
eyes of god right now all of us are
midgets and i say use that word
respectfully we are small
you know when adam sees how small we are
he'll probably collapse in shame and
shock because when he died people were
still his size
but after the flood the size of the
human race declined rapidly along with
the length of life
in the new world we shall grow
grow grow grow
in uh our eternal life with christ
what's the third part of that question
the third part is will we remember loved
ones yes
i shall be known even as also i am known
first corinthians 13. so yes we shall
know loved ones of course
the next question is how do we explain
romans 5 14 in the light of resurrection
romans 5 14
says nevertheless death
from adam to moses even over them that
had not sinned after the similitude of
adam's transgression who is the figure
of him that was to come
all right well let's read from verse 12
wherefore as by one man sin entered into
the world and death by sin and so death
passed upon all men for that all have
sinned but until the law death was in
the world but sin is not imputed
where there is no no law okay now verse
14 says nevertheless sin reigned from
adam to moses even over them that had
not sinned after the similitude of
adam's transgression what does that mean
adam's transgression was a willful
violation of god's law the bible tells
us clearly in first timothy 2 13 14 the
woman was deceived the man was not he
said willfully called dudely flagrantly
deliberately intentionally he violated
god's law
since adam's sin and eve every child who
comes into the world comes into the
world needing salvation so in that sense
death reign over everyone including
those who had not sinned like adam in
other words even the baby in the cradle
needs to be delivered from the
condemnation why because all of us come
with this nature and we have to be
delivered everyone who comes into the
world needs a savior even though we've
been out of sin the way adam did because
a six-year-old baby a six-month-old baby
has to not send away adam's sin because
sin is a moral choice
and so that's what that means not after
adam's civility not willfully with the
knowledge of right and wrong even those
who have not gotten that state they
still need a savior
thank you
read some questions from the chat
because
james had said
pastor keith since we rise in flesh and
bones and living in heaven i always
wondered if we will have to get rid of
any waste from our bodies as we have to
do in this life
i don't know
i really don't know
i have absolutely no clue the bible
doesn't tell us by the way the person
said we live in heaven we'll only spend
a thousand years in heaven our permanent
home is this earth made brand new so we
talk about going to heaven going to
heaven that's true but it's only a
temporary state christ will come back
after a thousand years destroy the
wicked remake this earth this will be
our prominent home by the way it will
also be the new location of god's
headquarters for the entire universe
this earth but i don't know about waste
disposal i don't
there's nothing in the bible that i know
of that addresses that point when i get
there i'll find out
another question is
from janissa vossian i don't know if i
said that right
the question was will we remember the
wicked things we did on the earth when
we get to heaven
no a lot of things we will not remember
um
the bible [clears throat] says in isaiah
65 17 behold i create a new heaven and a
new earth and the former things shall
not be remembered not coming to mind
because they'll be remembering those
things will have no spiritual benefit it
will bring no joy you see now we will
remember them during the thousand years
because during the thousand years sin
has not yet been dealt with completely
satan is still alive with its evil
angels the wicked the dead but the plan
of salvation is not yet complete until
christ comes back this the third time
destroys the wicked remakes the earth
then
it's all finished because as a zeal the
devil is finally destroyed the last one
that will be destroyed is satan the
earth remained new so in the thousand
years yes we'll remember but after that
no
but christ will always have the marks of
the crucifixion so there may be
something will remember not a life of
sin no remembrance of sin has no
spiritual value
it depresses
okay thank you so the last question is
what is the sign of jonah and its
relationship
to jesus's death and resurrection
what is the relationship between the
resurrection and baptism by immersion
the sign of jonah matthew 12 45 as jonah
was in three days and three nights in
the whale's belly even so shall the son
of man be three days and three nights in
the heart of the earth and so jonah
spent three years tonight in the whale
christ was sitting here three nights in
the heart of the earth in other words he
was buried now that's three days three
nights does not mean three literal days
at night it was just an expression
referring to any part of each day
but part of the first day he was in the
grave part of the second small part of
the third that counts was three or three
nights in the jewish mind and so it is
just christ is using that as a symbol of
the fact that he too would be buried
within something for three days three
nights as jonah was three days three
nights in the whale's belly christ will
be in the belly of the earth or the
heart of the earth now what's the second
part of that question
the second part of the question is
what is the relationship between the
resurrection and baptism by immersion
oh romans chapter 6 verse from verse 1
what shall we say then shall we continue
and say that grace may abound god forbid
how shall we that the dead to sin live
any longer therein and knowing not that
so many of us as were baptized into
christ were baptized into his death in
other words you must participate in the
death of christ before you participate
in the resurrection of christ because
there are two events the death and the
resurrection
someone coming to christ must die with
christ on the cross you die to your past
life you die so completely that you're
literally dead and are buried you see
you don't bury your living person you
don't bury a half dead person a half
dead person is still alive and many
people come to christ only half dead to
the past life we must die
when the soldiers came to the cross to
check the three prisoners christ and the
two thieves they wanted to break their
legs to hasten their death they found
that christ was already dead in
revelation 1 18 christ said i was dead
we must be dead with christ our past
life that we might rise so when you're
buried in baptism it symbolizes that you
were truly you've given up your past
life now you're being buried and only
the dead should be buried when you come
out of the water it is the newness of
life spoken of in romans 6 4 as he was
buried even so we rise to walk in
newness of life
the same way when the literal
resurrection comes we shall live a new
life in the new world with christ
thank you question i had is can you
please explain the absent from the body
is to be present with the lord so that
is second corinthians 5 verse 8. that's
that's uh
a lot of sunday people use that to say
when you die you go straight to heaven
the text is it the text is to be absent
from the body is to be present with the
lord it doesn't say when because at some
point after you absence for the body yes
you'll be present lord but when it
doesn't say when it doesn't say
immediately it does not say when and the
saint paul who said that he said in
first thessalonians 6 4 16 for the lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout with the voice of the archangel or
if the trump of god and the dead in
christ shall rise first paul cannot
contradict himself the same paul tells
us in first corinthians
15 verse 20 for since by man came death
by man came also the resurrection of the
dead
was as in adam all die even so in christ
shall all be made alive first
corinthians 15 20 and 21 22 and so paul
makes it clear in other places
that at death we go into the grave and
that's where we come from when jesus
christ come back so when he says in in
the absence from the body is to be
present with the lord he doesn't mean
immediately he does not mean that
because other statements he makes makes
it clear he does not mean that absent
from the lord absent from the body means
you're dead yes one day yes you'll be
present with the lord but not right
after you die because not even jesus
right after he died went to the father
he was in the grave
and if jesus didn't go immediately why
could i why can i why should i go
immediately or anybody else for that
matter
thank you i have another question
back to the question that we were
talking about the relationship between
resurrection and baptism of emergencies
we were talking about how people go into
the water that is dead and when we come
back we come back into a new life so a
question would be
yes so a question would be um does it
really matter how many times we do that
because there's a lot of people who you
know they go back to get baptized you
know [clears throat] one or two times
a certain point is there a certain point
where it's like is that really enough
bible does not tell you how many times
to be baptized we know the 12 disciples
who were re-baptized by paul in acts 19
1-7 paul met them
he asked which baptism do you receive
the said baptism of john then they never
heard the holy spirit because paul said
have you received the holy spirit since
he believed they said we never heard if
there be any holy spirit then he
preached to them of the holy spirit and
they were re-baptized 12 disciples so
re-baptism is biblical evangelism page
375 ellen white writes when a soul is
truly reconverted let that soul be
re-baptized let him renew his covenant
with god and god will renew his covenant
with him reconversion must take place in
the churches and so re-baptism is
oftentimes a very excellent decision
people need to make but i'm not saying
you get re-baptized every time you you
break the sabbath or you you know smoke
a cigarette or something i'm not saying
that i'm simply saying re-baptism is a
biblical event
it's between the person of god to decide
if he or she should do it
but no outside power can determine your
conscience on that point
but you can be provided with guidance
from the leaders guidance but the
exercise of your conscience that's your
domain
but real baptism is a biblical concept
thank you and the last question that i
have
is will we live in houses in the new
earth
well yes
[snorts] if you read john 14 1 to 2 let
nothing 23 let not your heart be
troubled you believe in god believe also
in me in my father's house on many
mansions if it were not so i would have
told you i go to prepare a place for you
i mentioned for you so yes what they
look like we don't know but the old
testament also tells us we shall build
houses and inhabit them so yes it will
be a real life it won't be people
floating around like clouds it will be a
real three-dimensional life the
difference is no sin
god has an entire universe to run he has
creations of whole we will help him do
that we will be busy we will live places
we'll travel differently but we will
have a real flesh and blood life
and one of the great things of the
gospel jesus will live that life with us
he will always retain his humanity he
has it now
so he will be with us he looked more
like us than he looked like god because
god is a spirit you don't see god you
know the way you see a human being a
spirit is not three dimensional as far
as we know a human being is so we shall
live a very very involved active visual
life we shall eat we shall drink we
shall fellowship we shall keep the
sabbath we shall build houses yes we
shall do that
the thing the thing missing will be no
sin consequently we shall do it in the
very presence of god we shall walk with
angels talk with god face to face ah how
can anyone miss that
and i look forward to that oh god bless
you sister please god bless you so do i
maybe you and i can live on the same
street with sister dinosaur uh my
curtain
yes yes yes
thank you so much
for answering
god bless god bless you
thank you god bless you too
thank you so much sister alana for
asking those questions and thank you
elvis keith for coming through with the
answers and as you were speaking about
um paul paul's statement in second
[clears throat] corinthians chapter five
verse eight the bible reads lord just
continue to speak through us in jesus
name amen
we are confident i say and willing
rather to be absent from the body and to
be present with the lord so paul is
saying i'm willing rather to die now
wait for that resurrection and live with
jesus than to be here on this earth and
suffer more persecutions and trials and
tribulations and as you rightly said um
elders keep
when jesus died he didn't go straight to
heaven
yes and i i know often times we look at
what jesus said on the thief
said to the thief on the cross which is
today thou shalt be with me in paradise
but originally there was no punctuation
marks in the bible when it was
translated so that comma is misplaced it
should it should be
before
um today
but
indeed we do not go to heaven
immediately after dying okay
true
all right so elder skeet you actually
answered question six uh six questions
that i had about the
many bodies of saints would slept that
arose right jesus died so we're going to
go to question seven which is what is
the difference between resurrection and
translation all right
translation means the absence of death
as you move from earth to heaven enoch
was translated that he should not see
death
uh hebrews 11 verse five enoch was
translated that he should not see death
a translated person does not experience
death moses was resurrected but he was
not translated he was resurrected elijah
was translated enoch was translated
moses was resurrected and taken to
heaven so when in matthew 17 verses 1 to
he not not you know yes
elijah and moses appear with christ on
the mount of transfiguration elijah
represented those who will not see death
will go straight to heaven
moses represents those who will die and
then be resurrected and so translation
means no experience of death enoch and
elijah resurrection is you die then you
come up moses represents that truth
[snorts] now the 144 000 will be
translated they will not see death
it's a tremendous privilege to not see
death and go straight to the kingdom
it's a tremendous honor it will preserve
an entire group in the past two people
have experienced that as far as we know
enoch and elijah before christ when
christ comes the last in the second time
an entire group of people at church will
be translated
hallelujah i'm looking forward to that
day by god's grace
yes and i'm looking forward to that day
and just to add a text to what you said
in first corinthians chapter 15 verse 51
the bible says we shall not all sleep
that's right let's all be changed that's
right
that's right that's very true
means death
pardon
sleep means death in the bible sleep is
dead we shall not all sleep we should
not all die
but whether you resurrected or
translated you have to be changed
that's right that's right and
[clears throat] i think that's where the
spiritual application of the
resurrection comes in because paul talks
about dying daily yes he does
but dying daily to self into sin
we're killed we're killed all the day
long and for thy sake we're killed all
the day long is a constant dying a
constant resurrection yes
amen amen well questions are flowing in
but i had received this question from
brother jonathan david archie um who
whom you know very well he acts when
jesus was on the cross and said my god
my god why hast thou forsaken me in
matthew chapter 27 verse 46
did god turn his face from the son or
did the father really forsake jesus but
jesus can't lie when jesus said why hast
thou forsaken me is because the father
had forsaken him in the sense that he
turned away because all the sins of the
world were christ remember isaiah 59 1-2
your iniquities have hid his fears from
you and your sins that he will not hear
you you say god doesn't look upon sin
all the sin was on christ
in galatians 3 13 christ said christ is
christ hath redeemed us from the curse
of the law being made a curse for us
well who made him a curse for us the
father so the father had to turn away he
did not leave the cross in the darkness
he was there but he turned away there
was a separation between the two
the father and the son which had never
occurred before
never occurred before and it really hurt
the godhead that that occurred the
father said it will never happen again
it's like taking a piece of material and
then you tear it that's what happened
when christ said why has thou forsaken
me and it hurt the father deeply it hurt
the son it hurt the spirit and the
father said it will never
never happened again so yes the father
turned away and christ was by himself
in that sense but the father was in the
darkness but he had to turn away and so
it's the christ for a while lost
the comfort of the present the father's
face
he withdrew his beams of love from the
sun and favor he withdrew them and the
angels were shocked when they saw that
wow wow
that happened they would have a
different look at sin altogether the
father withdrew his beams of faith and
love from the son on that cross that's
why he cried out he couldn't take it
why has thou he took a lot of suffering
but he couldn't take that he cried out
while forsaking me and the father for
him so he wouldn't have to forsake you
and me
wow
i tell you the poignancy of the cross
and what jesus
took on our behalf even separation from
the father
so that we could be saved
so why spurn salvation it is full and
free through jesus
but let me also say this god was in
christ reconciling the world and himself
so in a certain sense god experienced
what christ experienced
because god gave himself in christ
now it's a treatment that god gave
himself in christ he
worked out a way to give himself for the
race he gave himself in christ the bible
says god was in christ reconciling the
world reconciliation requires death
romans 5 verse 10 somehow now i'm not
saying the father died but he
experienced what jesus experienced
because christ experienced death in the
garden of gethsemane without physically
dying let me say that again
hebrews 2 verse 9 says he tasted death
for every man to taste death you have to
be alive to taste it christ experience
death while he was still alive no one
else has had that the father suffered
with the son in a real sense the father
experienced what christ experienced now
christ in his physical condition
actually died the father is not physical
so he couldn't die but he experienced
what jesus experienced
and since hebrews chapter 9 verse 14
says christ offered himself through the
eternal spirit the spirit suffered and
the angels suffered all of heaven
suffers
to save you
to save one human being all the godhead
all the angels went through that
suffering
salvation is expensive
but free
wow wow praise god praise god
thank you so much for those responses
elder skeet we greatly appreciate your
time
now we have a couple of more questions
in the chat and i think we may have to
just axe these
and then close out so
i'll start with the first one this is
from sister cassandra james while living
on
while living in the earth made new since
we will not be having a day-to-day job
as citizens of heaven what will one do
there as time pass passes i understand
that there will be no night there
all right let me pray again fathers we
come to the conclusion continue to speak
through me i pray and anyone else who
has to make a comment in jesus name amen
work is introduced in the bible in
genesis 2 15 and the lord god took the
man and put him into the garden of eden
to dress it and to keep it now the lady
said we won't have any jobs we will have
jobs what she means is there won't be
salaries attached to jobs the
work was not invented with salaries
salaries came in a result of sin when
god gave adam his work there was no such
thing as salary but work is essential
for character development
in john chapter 5 verse 17 jesus says my
father worketh in the two and i work the
father is always working the son is
always working the spirit is always
working the angels are always working we
will be working now we may not
understand the details of what we'll do
from day to day now when we say there
shall be no night there the morning and
the evening were the first day there
will be a dark and a light it may not be
the way we know it now
but there will be evening and morning
how else can we tell what day is the
sabbath we will still have days in the
new world so when it says for instance
revelation 21 1 and i saw a new heaven
and a new earth for the first heaven was
passed away and the first earth will
pass away and there shall be no more sea
of course there will be a sea but it
won't be as fast as the pacific which is
the result of the flood there will be
bodies of water so when we say no more
sea or no sun
you know they have no need of the sun
revelation tells us not that it won't be
present but the light of god will be so
great that it will douse the light of
the sun but we'll have the sun we'll
have the moon because they were part of
the original sinless creation you
understand night and day was part of the
were part of the original creation
evening and morning they will be there
but perhaps they look different from as
we know it now when i was a boy you walk
at night on the moon it was so bright it
was so clear and i guess all the people
can tell you that you can walk clearly
in the moonlight it was clear that's not
the case now night seems to be much
darker today for whatever reason and so
back to work we will have work to do
because work is part of the divine
nature we do not serve an idol god if
you look at your physical construction
even if you sit quietly there is
something going on in your body the
blood is flowing the atoms are moving
something is going on there is no such
thing as absolute stillness in god's
system so we will work the details of
that work will be made known to us when
we get there we will work
but we don't need salaries
amen amen thank you so much elder skeet
our next question comes from mark
anthony cromwell and he asks how do we
grieve for an expected loss of a loved
one
how do we grieve an expected loss of a
loved one
sorry for an unexpected my bad how do we
grieve for an unexpected loss of a loved
one thank you for repeating that
okay it's all right
grief very personal thing people grieve
differently grief is very you cannot
prescribe the person how to grieve grief
is very very personal there's a shock
element involved when it happens
unexpectedly but if i've got my mother
in the hospital six months she's on a
ventilator well i'm expecting something
to happen when it happens i'm not dating
by surprise but if my 40 year old
brother just drops dead then it's
unexpected but grief is a personal
personal thing and for the christian the
christian leans on god the christian is
still hurt the christian feels the loss
the christian feels the pain the
christian cries but a christian does all
of that leaning on god who is ever who
is the resurrection and the life he
leans on god who by his very life his
health and strength he leans on god who
is the resurrection when we shall see
that lost person again and so grief is a
personal experience and no one person
can tell someone else how to grieve but
you can support that person be with the
person
listen to the person and just be a rock
for that person but grief is individual
but christian does not breathe like a
non-christian
he does not first thessalonians 4 14 13
and 14. we we grieve not as others who
have no hope the christian grieves
knowing there's hope but he grieves
simply because he or she is human and
psalm 103 verse 14 he knows our friend
he remembers that we're dust and dust
breathes dust cries dust regrets thus
wishes the person can come back dust
does all of that and god understands
amen amen thank you all the skeet and i
see sister stacy i'm putting in the chat
chat lean on god
on god now we have another question from
youtube from jerry2x45
it reads
christ is the lamb slain from the
foundation of the world
when did this happen
okay good
good question let me pray again father
very powerful question from this brother
give me wisdom i pray please in jesus
name amen
christ did not die physically from the
foundation of the world but the promise
of god is so powerful
once god makes a promise that promise
exerts an effect
the promise was that a savior would come
and it is hinted at in genesis 3 15 i
will put enmity between thee and the
woman thy seed mercy the first mention
of the gospel the plan of salvation was
devised before adam was made
when he sinned that plan went into
operation and so even though christ died
physically 4000 years later
abraham was saved by the blood of christ
there is only one way to be saved and
that is by faith in the sacrifice of
jesus christ if from adam down to
malachi that's how people were saved not
simply when christ died and so the
effectiveness of christ's blood operated
even in the old testament but it was
provisional
it was ratified when he actually died it
was provisional in the old testament
because if christ had changed his mind
and gone back then that would have been
cancelled so the death of christ was
effective but provisional it was
rectified when he actually literally
physically died on the cross of calvary
and so because it was effective in the
old testament he is described as the
lamb slain from the foundation of the
world there would have been no other way
for adam and eve to be saved or for
abraham or for noah of the seth of
hashem to be saved but by the blood of
jesus christ so yes he's the lamb slain
but did not physically die until four
thousand years later
amen amen thank you eldesquite you see
the word of god is so powerful that what
he states it says it's as if it has
already happened yes
and just to add on we also see that in
luke chapter 20
where jesus tells the pharisees well the
sadducees really the sacrifices because
the sadducees didn't believe in the
resurrection
he says
now this is in verse 37 of chapter 20.
[clears throat] now that the dead are
raised even moses shoot at the bush lord
please continue to guide us in jesus
name
when he calleth the lord the god of
abraham and the god of isaac and the god
of jacob for he is not the god of the
dead but the god but of the living for
all live unto him
and i read desire of ages page 60 page
606 paragraph one and ellen white
explains that
god would resurrect abraham and isaac
and jacob so it was as if they we
already are living unto god
that was just a little connection there
even that's what you were saying that's
how jesus was slain from the foundation
of the world
and uh in terms of the other part of
your question brother jerry you can find
that verse in revelation chapter 13
verse 8.
okay
so let me ask
some other questions that are on zoom
all right
all right so
this question is
pastor skeet
well i i think we've covered one of
those already about the sabbath and so
forth
okay
someone has asked declan will we sleep
in the new earth will there be no night
there will be night there as i said
earlier perhaps not as we understand it
now but there was evening on morning
before there was sin you see that's how
a day is demarcated evening and morning
and so we have to believe it will be
also in the new world but perhaps not
quite the way we know it now
mankind was made to sleep
we were made to sleep sleep is part of
what's required for the restoration of
the body a physical body
must be made to rest any machine whether
animate or inanimate must rest from time
to time the sabbath is continuing proof
that we must rest part of rest is sleep
so i believe we'll sleep yes
amen amen thank you eldesquite
the next question is from trisha she
says who will be part of the 144
thousand i heard an elder at church say
he believes these are all sdas this is
true
but i'd like to see what bible verse
says then
the 144 000 will be all those who obey
god fully
that's as far as i can those who are
obedient to god because the bible says
here is the patience of the sins here
that keep the commandments of god in the
faith of jesus now the character of god
is most clearly expressed in his law
other than the life of christ the 144
000 will have that character in their
foreheads
on this earth before he comes by the way
all those who finally go to heaven will
have it so i cannot say 142 thousand
only will be
averages it will be those who have
committed themselves to obey god rather
the beast are you following me because
there'll be two competing powers as they
are now
thus saith the lord and thus save the
beast and the world and the worlds of
the beast are all the same thing because
you don't have three groups the wheat
the tears and the something else is weak
until sheep and gold so you have the
obedient people of god and everyone else
and everyone else includes the beast the
false prophet the world whomever
those who are in 144 000 will be those
who have chosen to obey god
fully even if it means the loss of life
they don't care kill me i'm obeying god
i will not obey a man made system whose
words country god and so obedience to
god becomes a a distinguishing mark of
the 144 thousand and that's what i'd say
those who made up their mind to obey god
even unto death
as we read in revelation 2 verse 10 be
thou thief unto death and i will give
the crown of life that's the 144
thousand
amen amen
now elder skeet
uh this next question is from sister
cassandra james again she asks is it
correct to believe that persons who died
and didn't get a chance to keep a
sabbath will get a chance to experience
a sabbath on their journey to heaven
if this may be her yes
the servant of the law tells us that yes
i don't recall where she writes that but
she does say that
you see everyone who finally walks
through the pearly guests would have
kept all ten of god's commandments
and the journey from earth to heaven is
about seven days so in that time yes
there will be established observance in
space can you imagine that
a sabbath observance in space
the service led by christ millions maybe
billions of people and the angels just
watching the unfollowed worlds just
watching as the redeemed observe the
sabbath after that then the entire host
can pass through the pearly gates yes my
good sister there will be opportunity to
do that you see there is no excuse for
law breaking there must be total
obedience to god that is the
qualification that is found in the lives
of christ given to us
amen amen can you imagine us just
hovering and singing with our hearts and
ah praise god praise god
now i will make this the last question
elder skeeter this is the final part of
brother jerry's question because where
in scripture can we find the father and
the son deciding to save humans
all right there's a ah that's a good
question that texas come to mind there's
a there's a council of peace
i'll find that i'll send it to you by
text you can perhaps forward it but
there's a text we talked about that
comes to the peace between the father
and the son i wonder if it's in
zechariah i'll find it and i'll send it
to you yes
thank you so i believe we
well i don't want to push it someone is
asking what did we miss on 1888 but we
had already spoken about you know
there's no prophetic you know landmark
beyond 1844. and it is 259 and i want to
keep to my word that we're
well it's okay that's another question
it's all right okay so what did we miss
on 1888
what is that what i don't get the
question yeah i'm not too sure myself so
we'll we'll leave that alone we'll leave
that alone but thank you sister elory
for
ants asking that
um we already spoke about the new bodies
the fact that we we likely maybe may be
sleeping as well since rest is being
will be uh continued on in the sabbath
likely to be physically resting but
guess what we'll know definitely if
we're there so that's what we have to
make up our minds to do too all right
there to be there
okay and i see
uh 7-7 prayer and health ministry says
put zechariah chapter 6 verse 13 in the
chat let me quickly
in the youtube chat he's been the father
in the channel
perhaps that is it let me quickly flip
through
dale please continue to guide us in
jesus name amen the bible reads even he
shall build the temple of the lord and
he shall bear the glory and shall sit
and rule upon his throne and he shall be
a priest upon his throne and the council
of peace
shall be between them
amen
that's a hint about the reason between
the father and the son from way back
from way back
regarding what to do with the fallen
world yes but it calls for a lot of
study to see exactly how it says them
amen amen any other question
no i believe
that is it okay oh sorry i'm so sorry
okay okay inherently sister cassandra
james
do you still have your hand up to ask a
question sister cassandra
okay she says no she says no
let me see yes
we talk about the second coming of the
resurrection but we also with the
resurrection we should keep in mind what
peter tells us in second peter chapter 3
verse 11 seeing them that all these
things shall be dissolved what manner of
persons ought to be in all holy
conversation and godliness looking for
and hasting under the coming of the day
of god in other words peter's saying
look you know there'll be a resurrection
you know there's a second coming if you
know that how should that affect your
present life it's one thing to discuss
the resurrection who will come up when
where what all that's fine but you can
do that in a disconnected way and it has
no effect on your personal life peter
says look if you know this event is
coming shouldn't that affect your
day-to-day life the way you live the
priorities what you spend your time
doing and i think we ought to take that
that thought
if there's a resurrection
is my life moving in the direction of
participating in the first resurrection
which is the resurrection of the just as
i examined my life for the past six
months which direction am i moving up or
down so we need as we discuss the
resurrection or we come to the
conclusion
am i ordering my life in harmony with
the imminent return of jesus christ am i
living in such a way that i realized
there is something called the
resurrection
and whether i participate in the first
or the second is entirely up to the
choices i made and so let us not just
make this an academic exercise
make a personal choice
is my present lifestyle jeopardizing my
chances of getting into the first
resurrection of the second perhaps i did
not say the right way but i think you
understand what i'm saying we must take
a personal view because someone
listening to me can die tonight god
forbid
personal response to this question and
answer session
does someone listening need to make a
decision to be re-baptized
decision to stop working on the sabbath
there's someone listening need to make a
decision to start returning the tie does
someone listening to me need to make a
decision to break up that romantic
relationship that has disgraced god what
decision do you have to make having
heard what you heard about the
resurrection that's coming
and i think that needs to be said that
needs to be considered what is my
personal response to this thing called
the resurrection and the return of
christ
amen amen thank you so much aldiskeet
for that call
to introspection
thank you so much and i think to me
needs to be re-baptized i know that i
don't know who but someone listening to
me needs to call the pastor and say
pastor have been convicted i need to be
re-baptized and start again with god all
over this time by his grace get it right
someone listening to me or someone's
need to make that decision
amen amen and i will see if i can put
the number for my church
to get in contact with my pastor in the
chats on zoom youtube please do and and
facebook
let me
i will ask my mom to send it over to me
so that i can do that and i see three
other persons have asked questions about
elder skeet okay that's fine
okay
in fact really four but i'll
i'll start with uh sister
well let me start with rodney smith he
says elder i have a question
why are there 13 tribes made mention of
in numbers 2
and throughout the old testament pattern
this number is kept in other words
northern tribe 10
and the southern tribe hand judah
benjamin and levi
the seven tribe the seven kingdom was
jude and benjamin
the northern kingdom were the other ten
tribes i don't know why the thirteen
mentioned in this chapter he said and
twelve elsewhere but if you look at the
sons that abraham not abraham jacob had
in genesis 29 and 30 he had 12 sons
you look at revelation
7 he had 12 sons
well the 12th mentioned of course
manasseh was not a son of um of jacob
although he's mentioned in uh so the
number is 12 in revelation 7 12 in
genesis 30 29 and 30. and that's as much
as i can say but they're not 13 sons
jacob had jacob had 12.
amen okay now sister patricia davey had
asked before why do we grieve over death
because we're human beings
you see human beings have an emotional
structure
we miss and god understands
that that's why as i said earlier psalm
103 verse 14 he knows our frame he
remembers it where does when when god
killed the child that
came from
david's association with bathsheba he he
lay on the floor for three days wouldn't
he when he was grieving until god
commanded him to get up people grieve
that's why david said in psalm 56 verse
8 he keeps my tears in a bottle god
understands that grief is one of the
consequences of sin so grief is not a
sin we grieve christ went to be with
mary and martha when lazarus died he
knew he would raise him but there was
still reasoning so grief is a human
reaction to loss
and god is not opposed to people
grieving we're told don't grieve like
unbelievers first thessalonians
13 14 we have hope but the christian can
grieve as a matter of fact refusal to
grief can result in physical sickness
you must grieve and release
now if someone has come to the part
where the faith is so strong that you
don't grieve or find blessings upon you
but most people have to breathe
that is true amen amen
all right so i believe sister laurie and
brother j well brother jerry pretty much
clarified sister lori's question i think
she was referring [clears throat] to the
1888 general conference
so she's asking um what happened on 1888
uh
if i guess how is that connected to our
time i guess this generation yes the
most famous general coming from session
in the history the church it was held in
minneapolis in the latter part in the
fall october and september something
like that anyway uh the issue a lot of
people have is that the concept of
righteousness by faith was presented by
wagner jones i was largely rejected by
church leaders that's what that's what
i've read
and uh eloise himself said that light
came was rejected the holy spirit was
insulted he was slapped
and she also wrote that god wanted to
come shortly after 888 but because of
the way the truth was handled he did not
come back um so it is a significant
watershed period in the life of the
church you understand but there's
nothing to prevent us from rediscovering
the truth by living by natural so that
christ can come it has been how many
years now since 1888. you know you had
12 130 something years since 1888 and
christ still has not come
and so it is not so much what happened
then but what can we do now
to bring ourselves by god's help into
alignment with the truth that jesus
christ might come back what can we do to
advance the gospel the bible says and
this gospel of the kingdom shall be
preached in all the world for the
witness and the whole nation then shall
the end come are we doing all we can are
we contributing are we investing what
are we doing to here in the coming of
christ i mean pining over 1888 will get
us nowhere what can we do now
so that we don't repeat whatever was
done in 1888 but it's a it's a it's an
interesting period of the church to
study it really is there are highs and
lows
during that time highs and lows
amen amen thank you elder skeet and i i
should say that we actually did a q a
session with elder skeet on a
righteousness by faith
so you can find that in the feel the
pillar series playlist
okay feel the pillar series playlist
righteousness by faith
now
sister cassandra
you have another question
okay is it okay her question is is it
wrong not to claim death i do not want
to see death and claim that
what is it i don't understand the
question
is it wrong not to claim death what does
that mean
all right well sister cassandra do you
want to unmute and clarify yourself okay
please
i'll move to another question then we
come back to that if she clarifies
okay
and i
i think
i think oh there we go okay so in the
meantime my mom has given the number for
our pastor pastor raymond alcock his
number is 718-961-0956
once again
718-916-0956
and i will put it in the chat this is to
contact the east new york seventh-day
adventist church
so let me put this in the chat
all right all this heat i think that
actually is the end of all the questions
all right okay
let me read this let me repeat someone
needs to call the pastor
and say pastor
i've been convicted i've made a decision
i need to be re-baptized someone
listening to me or someone
need or needs to do that and i hope you
will do it while the conviction is alive
because convictions wear away and once
they wear away it is unlikely they'll
return if you're convicted now contact
the pastor or some of the esca pastor
make your request known and follow the
procedure to and to be baptized and
resume your walk with god and god bless
you
amen amen thank you so much elder skeet
i'm going to quickly put this in the
chat for youtube so that person persons
can make contact that way as well
all right everyone well let me do the
vote of thanks
we thank god for the indwelling of his
holy spirit today and you heard elders
keep made the call for us to commit to
god whoever you are upon whose heart god
is working for you to be re-baptized
do not shun the spirit
do not shun the spirit make that
decision today and even for those of us
who may not be convicted to be
re-baptized but to live a renewed life
let us by the grace of god rise to the
occasion
now elder skeet our hearts are overjoyed
for your continual presence with us
and we are so grateful for your
commitment to the ministry of god and
for
even coming with us every month and
sometimes even twice a month to host
these q and a sessions your presence is
highly appreciated and we pray that god
would restore your strength the strength
of your wife and your entire family as
you labor for the master going near and
far all over the world declaring the
everlasting gospel amen amen
i should also say there may be someone
who's not the center of the adventist
but you have been associating with
adventists you've attended the service
you'll join into these q a sessions you
may need to make a decision to be
baptized and join the church please do
that
contact the leaders or your friends of
sda they will guide you through the
steps simple biblical follow through on
that and become one of us please
consider it and may god bless you
wherever you are
amen amen thank you elder skeet thank
you so so much
i also expressed thanks to sister alana
kwashi for assisting me in asking the
questions
um oh look at that i have totally
forgotten sister joanna smith will be
blessing us with a piece actually sister
joanna smith released yesterday an
original called live forever and i took
a listen to the song and i was blown
away at how doctrinally sound it is
um and her song is actually available on
all i believe music platforms on amazon
music and and so forth and she's doing a
great work even doing uh she's a civil
engineer correct
a civil engineering actually going back
to our communities and teaching our
youth about the sciences and the
mathematics and engineering and light
and how to grow our own food
friends she's raising some daniels and
shat and and hananiah missiles and
azarias so we'll be blessed as sister
joanna smith
ministers uh live forever but since i've
already started the thanks i'm gonna
thank you sister shirelle in advance for
doing the closing prayer and thank you
as well sister stacy ann for moderating
the chat cousin arrow for your technical
assistance my mom for your prayers and
all of you for tuning in asking your
questions and subscribing you may not
know this but these questions that you
ask
is going all around the world in fact
what person they will take these
questions and allow it to be broadcasted
so that others can be uh can have
clarity on questions that you may have
as well so continue asking your
questions in fact that's a beautiful way
to study the word of god ask questions
and pray for god to guide you to the
answer
and thank you as well mom for your
prayers and constant support and i'll do
the invitation to the next uh series and
the
youth revival after sister joanna smith
blesses us with her original live
forever
thank you
praise the lord everybody
um you know i'm just so blessed to be
here uh pastors pete thank you so much
um for that word and for denisha putting
this together uh you know the the word
that resonates with me is you know
what are we doing to make sure that
we're able to have eternal life um how
are we ordering our life so that god
will be pleased with us and that we can
live forever when he comes and so
um you know just a background to this
song really quickly i don't want to be
on here too long in 2018 i received this
song um
and it was really a struggle for three
years to put it out
um and i'm just so grateful to god even
during the season um that we're in in
corona and we've lost so many people
that we have hope amen that we will be
able to live forever when jesus comes
[singing]
we just thank god that we'll be able to
see his face soon
and very soon
i am going to live [singing] for every
year
[music]
oh [singing]
i am going to live forever
[singing]
[music]
foreign
[music and singing]
[singing]
oh so follow him as he leads [singing]
in righteousness the past will be easier
straight [music]
and it will progress
let the waves of his mercy
carry you through the process
make sure you're in the first
resurrection
when that trumpet found [singing] the
trumpets out so that you
can't live forever yeah [singing]
[singing]
[singing and music]
forever
oh
i [singing] am going to live forever
when [music] jesus comes [singing]
jesus comes for i know
this whole world
[singing]
we know that this whole world will soon
be [music] over
and we know it's important for us to
make sure that our mind is right our
life is right our soul is right for
christ when he comes so don't delay as
you all heard earlier today just
continue to invite god in your life and
make necessary preparations that you
need to make sure you are able to live
forever
when
he
comes [singing] so get your mind right
and don't you wait till it's over
get your soul
right on [singing and music] till the
back
so it's over
get your mind
[music and singing]
don't you wait
till it's over
so that [music] you
[singing]
oh
you
can't
live forever [singing and music] when
jesus
come on and say i am going to
[singing and music] live forever yeah
[music] oh thank god
i am going to live forever when jesus
[music and singing]
comes jesus comes
you hurt my cry
and supply so [music and singing] then
god i love you i can't wait for the time
when when jesus comes the air
oh say i am going to live forever
[singing]
[music] come on say i
[singing] when jesus [music]
comes jesus comes
be ready
amen amen powerful powerful thank you so
much sister joanna smith for that
message in song we need to get our minds
ready so that we can live forever once
again if you are being convicted by the
holy spirit to make a decision for god
do not delay
now is the time for salvation
now is the time to make our callings and
elections sure and if we want to live
forever we've got to hide our lives in
the life of jesus christ so call that
number
the number again
is
718-961-0956
get in touch with pastor alcock if you
want prayer if you want bible study if
you want baptism or re-baptism if you
want an anointing service or counseling
dial that number today even now if you
can
now is the time for salvation so thank
you so much sister joanna smith for that
ministration
and for those of you that have other
questions i saw some questions were
coming in on the youtube chat as we were
winding down
god willing those questions will be axed
next month
let me just share with you the next
program that we'll be having um it will
be august sabbath august 28th by god's
grace a q a with elder randy skeet on
probation once again same time same
place if you want to be able to ask your
question live you can join on zoom the
id is 679-742-1793
and the password is one two three four
five seven this is also live on youtube
and facebook brother jonathan david
archie will be assisting me in asking
the questions brother kevin gomez will
be ministering a song at the end and
sister stacy ann brown will be doing the
closing prayer
once again the id number is 679-742-1793
and the password is one two three four
five seven
now
i'm going to stop share and i invite all
of you to join us um the northeastern
conference personal ministries
federation is launching their youth
revival tonight at seven o'clock p.m on
their youtube channel and thank you
sister joanna smith for putting the link
in the chat where persons can listen to
and um
if they like oh no you know of course
after sabbath purchase live forever but
let me just share this and thank you
cousin earl for putting the fire up
share this promo video uh that brother
jonathan david archie and me had created
for this youth revival
and the theme is
look first ministries federation
presents
look up oh cousin arrow youth revival
with me hosted july 24 to august 7
nightly at seven o'clock p.m eastern
standard time except mondays because
days
jonathan david archie is the speaker
and denisha mccurchion the singing
evangelist
this revival also features the mount
vernon praise team shade forester the
calvary first nigerian choir oh dane
rhoden
praise the foster triplets jaleesia
scott genesis choir and much more this
is the time to experience a renewal of
your spiritual life
meetings will be hosted by the south
ozone sda church and live streamed on
the northeastern conference personal
ministries facebook page and youtube
channel this effort has been coordinated
by dr kendall guy sister suzanne jordan
anza and dr godfred anza now is the time
to look up
thank you so much cousin arrow for
sharing
that promo video and also the number to
call pastor alcock and please pardon me
i forgot the c after the o
um in pastor alcock's name but the
number is what is most important i will
not belabor the point we are over time
sister shirelle you may close us out
with a word of prayer thank you
okay
what a powerful program that we've had
today with elder skeet and we just want
to
pray and close out
let us pray
father in heaven lord we are thankful
that you're a holy god we're thankful
that your name is excellent we're
thankful that you're a living god that
you've made promises in your word that
are true and that are sure
we're thankful for the sacrifice of your
son that you've made lord we're thankful
that you've come down to this earth to
die for us so that we could have that
everlasting life
lord i pray that you would be with each
and every one of us oh lord forgive us
of our sins wherever we need a cleansing
in our hearts lord i pray that you'd
wash us and make us white as snow
help us lord to reflect on our lives and
just to prepare for the life to come
prepare for that eternal life and
promise and the mansions in heaven that
you've laid out for us
lord we are thankful for this program
for the elder for the questions and
answers that have been provided help us
to seek to understand for ourselves and
to get to know you better
i pray that you would bless everyone on
this line those who will view later
and their families help us to look
forward father to the resurrection
to come so that we can look in the sky
and say
this is our god we have waited for him
we thank you once again lord in jesus
name amen
amen and amen thank you so much sister
pierre for that closing prayer and thank
you to all of you for joining this
session today i pray that you are
blessed and i pray that we leave here
with a greater
drive to serve our lord and savior
living with hope
looking forward to that resurrection
and even if we do not die that when
jesus comes that we will be translated
if he comes in our lifetime may god
bless you and have a wonderful rest of
the sabbath day thank you